Ukraїner
Експедиція
[Наддніпрянщина,
Черкаси]
Це куточок з переробки пластику,
а вся інша майстерня у нас...
[Лідія Криштоп,
екоактивістка, співзасновниця лабораторії Preciouslab]
...як фаблаб іде, тобто це місце,
куди люди приходять вчитися робити щось своїми руками.
А ми їм допомагаємо навчитись.
Ідея була в тому, щоб показати людям,
що пластик — це цінний ресурс,
його не треба викидати.
Що його можна перероблювати 100500 разів
самим в себе вдома
або приходити до нас з кришечками
й робити якісь вироби.
Cпочатку проєкт «Precious Plastic»
з'явився років 5 тому
у данського дизайнера Дейва Гаккенза.
Він робив дизайнерські речі з пластику
і придумував, як врятувати планету
від пластикових відходів.
І вони з друзями придумали такі машини,
які можна зробити самотужки вдома
і в домашніх умовах перероблювати пластик.
Всі ці схеми викладені у вільному доступі.
Ми їх просто скачали і зробили таке саме.
Це шредер,
він перемелює пластик в пластикову крошку.
В ось таку.
Це ми на ньому
різнокольорові кришечки перемололи.
А екструдер,
який ми зробили буквально тиждень тому,
робить ось такі речі.
Вже з переробленого пластику.
Основні дилери — молодь,
яка приходить сюди
вчитися робити щось своїми руками.
Є екоактивісти, які роблять точки,
наприклад в магазинах чи аптеках,
куди люди приносять кришечки.
Вони нам мішками приносять.
Є в школах вчителі,
які з дітьми збирають кришечки.
Вони нам теж щорічно
десь близько 1 мішка збирають.
Ось тут в мене коробка зі «скарбами».
Її мені недавно принесли.
Кажуть, що цілий рік збирали
і ось принесли.
Ми кришечки сортуємо по кольору.
Вкидаємо в шредер за різними кольорами
і в пляшки збираємо кожен колір окремо.
Далі або в піч складаємо цю стружку,
де вона перепікається в пластини ось такі.
І потім з цих пластин ми щось вирізаємо.
Або скидаємо всю цю стружку в екструдер.
Будемо робити кошики, горщики.
Все, що можна намотати, будемо мотати.
Це громадська організація,
у нас 7 людей в команді.
Працюють на волонтерських засадах.
Просто познайомилася група людей,
які раніше самі по собі були.
Щось пиляли в себе в гаражі, експерементували.
Або дивилися відоси,
як інші люди експерементують.
І не було просто цієї спільноти людей,
які цю ідею в собі б поєднували.
Які ділилися б цим та разом щось придумували.
І ми вирішили,
що цю ситуацію в нашому місті треба змінювати.
Я навчалась на економіста-кібернетика.
І я собі обрала за тему економіку та екологію,
як вони разом співпрацюють.
Я досліджувала
як поганий стан екології впливає на економіку, ВВП.
І мене це дуже зачепило.
Бо якщо прибрати всі екологічні кризи, що стаються,
витратити гроші на те,
щоб очистити річки й повітря,
у нас залишиться від ВВП 1%.
Я пішла на конкурс громадських проєктів.
І одна з тем, яку можна було подавати на конкурс,
була екологічна.
Я написала проєкт з роздільного збору відходів.
І потім натрапила на цей проєкт із переробки пластику.
І така: я звільнюю світ від пластику!
Буду цим займатися.
Пластик — це тільки частина.
Взагалі ми тут вчимо людей технологіям.
Хочемо навчити
все робити своїми руками, а не купувати.
Тут можна зробити все з майже нічого.
Це робилося за допомогою фанери...
[Максим Скорик,
співзасновник лабораторії Preciouslab ]
лобзіка, креслення.
В майбутньому — це одна з деталей станка-фрезера
з новим програмним управлінням.
Він зможе обробляти
здорові листи переробленого пластику.
Вирізати меблі чи щось таке.
Це як раз змусить людей задуматися
про переробку, про економіку, про економію.
Бо нащо потрібна переробка? Тому що це економно.
А якщо це економно, то це економічно вигідно.
Я зараз займаюся тільки громадськими проєктами.
Один — це пластик, другий — майстерня.
Третій — це всеукраїнська акція,
де ми поєднуємо кав'ярні в екологічну мережу,
куди людина може прийти зі своєю чашкою,
налити в ту чашку каву
і їй зроблять знижку, бо вона зберігає природу.
Ми ось такий логотип даємо кав'ярням
і це означає, що вони беруть участь в цій акції.
З цієї весни акцію
підхопили активісти з декількох міст.
І вона вже в п'ятьох містах.
Ми поширюємося і акція діє вже не тільки в Україні.
Сама головна цінність — це люди.
Ми про це пам'ятаємо.
Ми відкриті для нових людей.
Ми їх будемо дуже цінити. І зараз цінимо.
Ми хочемо, щоб вони збиралися всі до купи
і народжували ще більше нових,
ще більше крутих технологій.
Разом це реалізовували.
Для цього це й було створено.
Щоб люди бачили,
що щось можна робити по-іншому,
що можна жити по-іншому.
Щоб збиралася група людей,
яка починає змінювати місто.
Це така глобальна ідея.
[автор проєкту: Богдан Логвиненко]
[оператори: Павло Пашко, Олег Сологуб]
[продюсерка: Оля Шор]
[режисер: Микола Носок]
[монтажерка: Юлія Рублевська]
[субтитрвальниця: Варвара Вербицька]